fest umklammert hält der achtjährige
miroslav die hand seines papas sein
oberschenkel zertrümmert durchschlagen
von der kugel eines russischen
scharfschützen der kleine miroslav liegt
gemeinsam mit seinem vater andré in der
kinderklinik von manager schwer verletzt
die mutter tot erschossen
das waren tiere die uns das angetan
haben sie haben doch gesehen dass wir
zivilisten sind der albtraum der
vierköpfigen familie beginnt am ersten
märz mit dem auto flüchtete aus peru
siefker einem westlich gelegenen vorort
von kiew dort tobt der krieg die mutter
sitzt am steuer miroslav und sein
zehnjähriger bruder anton auf den
rücksitzen plötzlich taucht eine kolonne
russischer panzer auf es fallen schüsse
eine kugel trifft mutter lana direkt in
die post sie ist sofort tot
ich finde keine worte meine frau seine
mutter ist erschossen wurden im moment
geht es nur darum dass miroslav wieder
gesund wird obwohl die schützen sehen
dass es eine familie mit kindern ist
schießen sie weiter an da wird in den
unterschenkel getroffen dann nimmt der
scharfschütze den kleinen miroslav ins
visier er trifft den jungen kurz
oberhalb des knies sie können sich
gerade noch hinter den wagen schmeißen
miroslav weint vor schmerz
dann kam einige russ sie beschimpften
uns noch einen namen mein handy weg
fragte mich ob ich aufnahmen von den
panzern gemacht hätte ein soldat wollte
miroslav dann helfen die blutung zu
stoppen das wollte bio nicht ich habe
dann seinen beiden abgebunden die
schwiegereltern bringen die verletzten
in ihre wohnungen die schmerzen werden
immer schlimmer quellen der sechs tage
später kommen vater und sohn ins
krankenhaus
miroslav wird operiert acht schrauben
fixieren seinen oberschenkel die
schwestern haben dem jungen malbücher
ans bett gebracht er hat sie nicht
beachtet nur die hand seines vaters hält
er fest umklammert